senator mccain's first answer to this  economic crisis was get ready for this a  commission that's Washington speak for  we'll get back to you later folks we  don't need a commission to spend a few  years and a lot of taxpayer money to  tell us what's going on in our economy  we don't need a commissioner to tell us  gas prices are high or that you can't  pay your bills we don't need a  commission to tell us that you're losing  your jobs we don't need a commission to  study this crisis you don't need  somebody to write a report to tell you  that unemployment is tough up here in  northern New Mexico or that unemployment  is bad on Indian country you don't need  a report for that what you need is a  president who will solve it and that's  the kind of president I intend to be